foreign
[Music]
this continent has some of the most
dramatic Landscapes on the planet from
the ocean shorelines
to the Alpine mountains
in the Sandy deserts
and also in this land mass from coast to
coast and everywhere in between there
lived hundreds if not thousands of
different nations tribes of people whose
land this was this was their home but
then others showed up to these
shorelines in their boats
and that is when everything changed
[Music]
okay
okay in the spring of 1803 two American
politicians visiting Paris closed the
sweetest real estate deal they had ever
seen with the simple stroke of a pen
their country doubled in size all for
just 15 million dollars but in this deal
which was called the Louisiana Purchase
the US didn't actually buy this land
from France France didn't actually own
the land what the United States was
buying was the Imperial rights to this
huge swath of North America this
basically meant that France would stay
out of the way and let the buddy new
Empire the United States colonize it
without interfering if the United States
really wanted ownership over this land
they would need to get it from the
people who were here first which at the
time was lots of different native tribes
these are the people who had been here
for thousands of years way before
Europeans had the idea of leaving their
continent and this land that the U.S
just bought was theirs
oh and this isn't just me like some
Modern enlightened person looking back
and judging the United States at this
time the U.S knew that this wasn't their
land and that they were going to have to
buy it from the people living there and
their big plan was to do things
differently not like the old Imperial
powers that they had just broken away
from in fact George Washington was quote
determined that the U.S government's
administration of Indian Affairs shall
be directed entirely by the great
principles of justice and Humanity go
USA let's do this in the right way so
instead of Conquest they would negotiate
and sign formal treaties with these
native nations then they would pay them
for their land farron Square
after all this was a country whose
founding document highlights Justice
Tranquility welfare and Liberty in our
series how the US stole we get to see
how the US Grew From A group of English
settlers to a global superpower but none
of those stories would exist without
this one the origin story the first
thing that the U.S ever stole
so Europeans are pouring into this newly
formed country the United States and the
government is making deals and signing
treaties with the tribes allowing these
newcomer immigrants to settle on their
land at first this is a fairly peaceful
transactional process the U.S would
offer food farming equipment cash the
services of a blacksmith all in exchange
for ownership over this land
but unsurprisingly a lot of these tribes
had no interest in moving out of their
ancestral lands in exchange for like
farming equipment and this is where all
of George Washington's ideals of justice
and Humanity really start to dissolve
the U.S was becoming a more powerful
Nation they needed more land for their
booming population so the impatient
settlers and their government started
playing dirty The Westward Movement was
like a great tidal wave you start to see
what happens when these tribes say no to
the newly powerful United States in one
instance one group of tribes up near the
Great Lakes didn't want to sell their
land they told the United States that
this River would be the border and to
not cross it to stay off their land the
U.S said no and they took them to war
and lost
twice but on the third time they won the
battle and forced the tribes to sign a
treaty giving away all of this land
basically all of present-day Ohio
something very similar happened down
here when the Seminole tribes refused to
leave their land the U.S military came
in another War killing thousands forcing
the tribes to sign a treaty and pushing
them into the swampy interior of the
state where they had no access to their
farmland or the ocean down here in what
was becoming Alabama the Muskogee Nation
refused to sign a relocation treaty but
not wanting to go to war agreed to sell
a portion of their land in return for a
guarantee that they could keep the rest
and the United States agreed and they
actually did and the Muskogee kept their
ancestral lands forever womp womp no
that didn't happen four years later a
bunch of white settlers moved in boxing
the Muskogee out of their ancestral land
as tensions grew because of this
violated agreement the U.S military was
called in to force the Muskogee out of
their lands no treaty was ever signed I
mean the shenanigans ranged the whole
gamut here they would get tribal leaders
drunk to trick them into signing this
paper that gave them all the land they
would appoint random people to be the
tribal leaders and then tell them to
sign away the land for the whole tribe
in another conflict the Sioux and
Arapahoe Nations defeated the US
military over and over until the U.S
finally signed a peace treaty
acknowledging their land
and they were safe
until gold was discovered eight years
later and the U.S broke their treaty
redrew the boundaries built roads on
their land and before you know it you've
got a bunch of white guys with gold pans
harvesting this land treaties and
Justice be damned
[Music]
but eventually other tribes caught on to
what was going to happen realizing that
refusing the US government would mean
violence so they would sign the paper
take the money and leave over the course
of almost 100 years the United States
signed 368 treaties with tribal Nations
who were driven out one way or another
to make way for white settlers who
established control over this land that
their government had stolen for them and
yes you have all the paperwork all the
spreadsheets that they were making all
the treaties a nice paper trail but this
was all a facade of Justice a thinly
veiled campaign for Imperial Conquest
before we go on to the story I just need
to tell you that we don't have a sponsor
for today's video lately I've been
hearing from some sponsors that my
videos are too political which is kind
of a bummer because we work really hard
to tell really cool stories and if that
means that uh people don't want to
sponsor us that's fine luckily we have a
patreon where all of you can support
this work it's called The Newsroom we
call it The Newsroom because it just
sounds cooler than patreon but it is a
place where you can support what we are
doing which is something more and more
we need on The Newsroom you get an extra
video every month it's a behind the
scenes Vlog from all of the people and
processes and happenings around here in
the studio you get to see my scripts you
get royalty free music from our composer
Tom Fox that you can use in your videos
and live q and A's with me members of
The Newsroom get to chat with me on a q
a uh where they can ask me anything but
more importantly you get the warm fuzzy
feeling of supporting independent
journalism and if that floats your boat
you can go to the link in my description
patreon.com Johnny Harris Let's Get back
to the story
okay so we have all of this like fake
treaty Shenanigans going on to help the
United States feel like they're doing
Justice and it's working they are moving
loads of native people out of their
ancestral lands so that white people can
settle it but there was one region that
proved particularly difficult for this
extermination project that was going
down here in the Deep South we had these
five large Nations that lived side by
side with the settlers for a long time
they had all signed treaties with the
United States that acknowledged their
right to this land many of them spoke
English practice farming wore European
clothes some even owned slaves because
of this these five tribes the Cherokee
Chickasaw Choctaw Muskogee and Seminole
were known as the Five Civilized Tribes
and there's an alternative world where
these tribes could have remained on
their land living side by side with the
Europeans as they settled but that's not
what happened mostly because of cotton
[Music]
farmers down here were getting super
rich off of a very valuable cash crop
called cotton that they could sell to
textile mills around the world it was an
industry made even more profitable by
its key input Free Labor from stolen
Africans there was this one strip of
land down here called the black belt
Prairie that was particularly desirable
for farming cotton but as you can see it
was locked up in what the United States
treaties had formally acknowledged as
belonging to native nations but the
farmers down here were looking at this
as like this is a perfect place to
expand our cotton Kingdom
so these southern slave owners did what
was kind of becoming U.S policy towards
the people living on the land that they
wanted they made up their own rules the
state of Georgia was particularly
aggressive in trying to clear this land
out or in the words of their governor at
the time to replace quote all of the red
with white population they targeted the
Cherokee Nation passing a law that
abolished their governments the Cherokee
are not going to stand for this so they
fight back using the same shenanigans
that the United States is trying to use
the U.S legal system they take Georgia
to court a case that went all the way to
the Supreme Court and guess what the
Cherokee Nation won like there was no
way around the fact that they had
Ironclad rights to this land signed and
sealed the highest court in the country
just ruled that the states could not
impose on tribal sovereignty but as we
all learned in government class A ruling
from the judicial branch only works if
the executive branch enforces it oh and
who is in charge of the executive branch
oh this guy
the guy who wrote a letter to his wife
during the War of 1812 from the
battlefield saying that he had
successfully slaughtered 170 Native
Americans in quote An Elegant Style Oh
and the guy who's on our 20 bill yeah
him Andrew Jackson thought that
negotiating treaties with the people who
were living here was a ridiculous notion
so he looks at the Supreme Court ruling
that validates the Cherokee's right to
their land and he literally responds in
the snarkiest way possible saying the
Chief Justice John Marshall has quote
made his decision now let him enforce it
no he was not going to enforce it
Jackson had a different plan in mind it
came in the form of a new law that he
pushed through both houses of Congress
his whole world view towards first
Americans embodied in a piece of
American legislation the Indian Removal
Act of 1830.
this law used taxpayer money to get
tribes out of the United States and to
relocate them to an uninhabitable place
that surely no American Settler will
ever end up the Great Plains seemed an
inhospitable land to people familiar
with the eastern states and of Europe
This became their dumping ground and it
came with a promise move here and we
will never mess with you again and
what's crazy to me is that even after
all of the shenanigans all the facades
they continued to play this charade
saying that the nation of Indians may
choose to exchange their land where they
now reside the law says that the
government had to negotiate these
treaties fairly voluntarily peacefully
and that the government would quote
forever secure and guarantee them their
new land and that they wouldn't break
any of the pre-existing agreements that
they had made in previous treaties but
no this was just more pretending a paper
trail of pretend Humanity just as Andrew
Jackson had ignored the Supreme Court
ruling he had no intention in following
the law that he helped create but he
kept up the ruse more documents more
signatures more paper that made these
civilized justice-minded people feel
like they weren't orchestrating a mass
ethnic cleansing sanctioned by the
government paid for by taxes but they
were so this law is implemented and the
United States government military and
even private companies start to ramp up
their removal efforts of first Americans
they focus in on these five tribes that
were sitting atop the land that they
wanted for their cotton Empire more
bribes more pretend negotiations and
when push came to shove more threats of
violence the Cherokee eventually signed
a treaty agreeing to sell their last
portion of land
and they moved West out to their little
rectangle of land that had been
allocated to them by the government on
maps the only problem was that the
leader who signed the treaty on behalf
of the Cherokee People was not actually
the real leader they had no authority to
make this decision the Cherokee Chief
furiously protested this but the U.S
didn't care they had their signature
from someone in their eyes all was
justified
between 1831 and 1838 nearly every
member from the five tribes was expelled
from their land a hundred thousand
people whose home this was now forced to
walk by foot for more than a thousand
miles through brutal weather and terrain
towards a little box on the map a place
they had never been before
the Cherokee would eventually call this
journey the trail where we cried or at
the Trail of Tears some tried to fight
back against their oppressors and others
stood their ground until they were
forcibly Bound in chains by the US
government and herded West at gunpoint
their land was vacant and cotton Farmers
with their slaves moved in and the
economy grew
[Music]
we'll never know how many people died
during all this how many lives were
really destroyed some people say 3 000
other estimates say 15 000 but you don't
need those numbers to see how
destructive this was it was systematic
it was documented and it was enshrined
in law we have a paper trail of all of
it showing the receipts the payments the
treaties the bureaucracy of it all it's
like a bunch of spreadsheets from the
1800s American settlers in an effort to
be different from the old world Empires
they fled ended up carrying out the
first state-sponsored ethnic cleansing
there's a reason why Hitler a hundred
years later references this exact event
this process when he was carrying out
his own ethnic cleansing he said that
the Volga which is a river in Russia
would be quote our Mississippi he said
that Europe not America would be the
land of unlimited possibilities
the story of what happened to many
nations of the first Americans doesn't
end here in fact this is kind of the
beginning we're going to make a second
part to this video and in that part two
I want to show you what happens next
once these tribes arrive to their little
rectangle on the map Indian Territory
the place where these tribes were forced
out dumped and left to build a new life
and how they once again tried to fight
back using the legal Frameworks that had
pushed them out and how all of that led
to the establishment of one state in our
country that could have looked a lot
different
[Music]
foreign
hey um thanks for watching this video I
need to tell you about something we have
a a poster I finally have a poster I've
been dreaming about this poster for a
very long time all maps are wrong and
indeed they are this poster shows dozens
of map projections all the weird quirky
shapes that you get when you try to map
a sphere which is what our globe is onto
a piece of paper which is flat is
available right now you can go buy it
and doing so supports this channel but
it also gives you a really sweet poster
um we printed it on really nice paper I
spent a very long time nudging every one
of these Maps I got help from some of my
best friends and designers like Becky
from Becky and Chris is like a really
good graphic designer I literally sent
her the illustrator file and I was like
hey can you like do this and she was
like I got you so she made it better
anyway it's a fantastic cool thing and
I'm really excited about it so Link in
the description we also have a big thing
going on over at patreon a few thousand
people are over there supporting us
um so that we can make more videos like
this something I am very grateful for so
that's patreon.com Johnny Harris
um what else do I need to tell you about
maybe things like Luts and presets we
use Luts to color our videos if I don't
put my Lut on this video it looks like
this
be really bad so we worked with a
professional colorist to make this Lut
so that our videos look like this and
it's much better so we do that also for
photos with presets for like Lightroom
and stuff those are available in the
description the startup that I founded a
few years ago is still cruising along
bright trip we're publishing courses
about cool places around the world you
can go check that out boy what else I
mean more importantly we're just going
to keep making videos so thanks for
being here
um we'll see in the next one
and tag Bonanza look at these people
foreign